voilà l'image de vos retrouvailles parce
qu'il faut bien comprendre que vous
étiez pas ensemble à ce moment là
comment ça s'est passé précisément vous
étiez séparés à quel moment vous êtes
vous retrouvée on le matin mais j'ai
vers 8h30 j'étais parti pour une fuite
de gaz dans la rue ou les pompiers
répondait et à ce moment là je pensais
que mon frère lui à l'être dans le
camion des pompiers alors que moi je
suis toujours dans la voiture du chef et
je n'ai même pas réfléchi je les ai pas
vus au coin de la rue je n'ai pas vu
quand je suis rentré dans la tour mais
c'était pour moi évident qu'ils étaient
dans le camion qui ensuite qu'il était
monté dans la tour avec les avec la
compagnie des pompiers
et je crois que j'ai on s'est retrouvés
il devait être environ une heure et
demie de l'après midi oui donc vous
l'avez cru vous vous avez craint sa
disparition oui j'ai je suis même pensé
au moment de mettre sortie des camps les
deux tours ce soit un problème j'ai
pensé pendant quelques heures qu'il
était mort comment avez vous pu
comment êtes vous arrivé à continuer à
filmer dans ce contexte là c'était en
fin de compte une espèce de mécanismes
de protection eu par nos films et
c'était une façon de regarder les images
la réalité que je voyais à travers le
petit écran sur le côté de la caméra est
une façon de mettre une barrière devant
moi donc ça devenait plus c'est une
façon de pas réalisé l'horreur en fait
eh bien merci merci beaucoup à vous deux
merci pour ce film dont il faut préciser
je crois que toutes les recettes iront
aux associations de victimes c'est bien
ça oui c'est un fonds qui est destiné
aux enfants des pompiers que ce soit les
pompiers qui sont morts pendant leur
travail mort en dehors du travail et
également tous les enfants des pompiers
qui sont qu'ils sont en vie et les
futurs pompiers des futures générations
merci merci beaucoup à vous deux est de
pouvoir annoncer ce soir que
l'intégralité de ce film sera diffusé
par france télévisions sauf surprise
vraisemblablement le 11 septembre
prochain